السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
منذ ايام وتحديدا في 18 مارس الفين وعشرين
اتفقت الثمن الدول الاعضاء في منظمه
شنغهاي للتعاون
الصين والهند وروسيا وباكستان وستين
وكازخستان وطاجكستان اوزباكستان بالاضافه
الاربعه المراقبه والعزه تصبح عضو منتظم
في المنظمه وهم ايران وافغانستان
وبلاروسيا ومن هنيه
على اجراء التجاره والاستثمارات بالعملات
المحليه الوطنيه بدلا من الدولار الامريكي
وبالتالي تحديد دور في المعاملات الثنائيه
اللي الحقيقه اللي مش او المحلي الدولار
شفنا اتفاقيات ثنائيه كثيره بين الدول على
تحييد الدولار الامريكي واستخدام العملات
المحليه في التسويه التجاريه يعني مثلا في
اواخر 2013 اتفاقات تركيا مع الصين وايران
على ان المعاملات التجاريه بالعملات
المحليه
شفنا الاتحاد الاوروبي
المقايضه اللي عمل والسنه اللي فاتت الفين
وسته اشهر اللي تحاول على العقوبات
الامريكيه وتحديد الدافع عن الدور الراي
يتخرجون هايدي الحرب العالميه الثانيه
اصبح الدولار العمله المخيمين في العالم
وبالتالي كانت الولايات المتحده بمزايا
المهمه وصف الرئيس الفرنسي السابق
بالامتياز وتحول دولار ليصبح الاحتياط
الاولى في العالم لدرجه انه اكثر من ستين
في المائه من الاحتياطيات النقطه المركزيه
في العالم
وبعد اليورو كعمله احتياطيه عالميه وعشرين
في المائه من احتياطي العالم القضايا
الخمس مائه وثمانين مليون دولار من
الاوراق انه قد يتم تداولها خارج الولايات
المتحده والتي الناتج المحلي الاجمالي في
العالم
دكتور بطانتها بالدور واربعين في المائه
من دون العالم بالدور
دوله والمطلوبه
حكومتها مثلا الولايات المتحده الكام يوم
الرئيس الفنزويلي نيكولاس مادورو وكان
بيشتغل راعي بقر
مادورو تشتري كان برميل نفط
لانه ببساطه محتله يشتري
من اي مكان في العالم بالدولار
الدولار في الاقتصاد الاعلامي بالشكل
المعقده منح الولايات المتحده تاثيره
استثنائيا على المسار الاقتصاديه للدول
الاخرى ولكن في عهد استخدمت امريكا سلطه
لاقصى حد بالانخراط في حرب واستخدام
الدولار اللي جندوا الدول في روسيا وايران
وكوريا الشماليه
والنتيجه لطيفه ان ادافع عن دول للسعي
للتحرر من الهيمنه الماليه الامريكيه
روسيا مثلا كل شيء امريكا تفرض على عقبات
جزيره القرار في الولايات المتحده فرضت
على عقوبات الصديقه وماليه قاسيه وتسببت
في الصدر وسبعين لحد الوقت من الاسباب
الانتقام الروسي من شركات النفط الصخري
الان السماح لاسعار النفط بالانهيار
الاقليمي عشرين دولارا للبرميل وبالتالي
افلاس كثير من الضغط على الحكومه
الامريكيه المهمه
بدات روسيا تنفيذ استراتيجيه طويله الاجل
وهي الغاء سواء في المعاملات المحليه او
التجاره الدوليه للتحايل على العقوبات
الامريكيه
نشوفها بشكل واضح يعني من 2013
للبنك المركزي الروسي
احتياطيات النقد الاجنبيه اكثر من اربعين
في المائه لاربعه وعشرين في المائه فقط
ومن 2018 الحد الوقتي انخفضت حيازات
الممكن دون الخزانه الامريكيه من حوالي
مائه مليار دولار ل اقل من عشره مليار
دولار في الخطه الثانيه الخاصه الدوله
السياسي الشركات الروسيه
والعمل المحليه الروبل الروسي في
المعاملات بما فيها شركات النفط والغاز
وعلاوه على كل ده ليس مع اي دوله من الدول
ان تعمل معها اتفاقيات لتسويه التجاره
الثنائيه بالعملات المحليه وبالتالي سلاح
الدور اللي بتستخدم والولايات المتحده
المنطقه الدول بان قلب عليه اللي بتدور
على اسئله للاطاحه بالدولار الوقت الهيمنه
الماليه الامريكيه الحاجه الثانيه يعني في
قوه عالميه صاعده
احتجاج بعض الدول تستغله في مصلحتها تفويض
سلطه الدوله مدافع عمليتها اليوم على
النقاط
المهم تعمل على سقوط الدولار وانهيار وعلى
شانه ان يحل محل بلا شك عندها قدره على
اسقاط دون اجراء واحد فقط يسمى الخيار
النووي هو ب يعني هل كانت الخزانه
الامريكيه واحد فوضى
في الاسواق العالميه
ويحصل
ببساطه هي اكبر ملك في العالم دون الحكومه
الامريكيه تمتلك اكثر من 1.1 تريليون
دولار من سندات الخزانه الحقيقه الفين
ممكن تحدث بالسلاح لا املك انما تستخدمه
فعلا
الاستثمارات
بالدولار بتستخدم سندات الخزانه دين في
المحافظه على القيمه وانخفض اليوان امام
الدولار وبالتالي تحافظ على صادرات
الولايات المتحده
امريكا السنه اللي فاتت 2019 بحوالي
اربعمائه وخمسين مليار دولار وبالتالي فمن
الغباء ان ا ا تسبب في اكبر
عايز انتقال ثالث وطويله القدم من الدول
انا عندي صور وعايزه
المنطقه انا اعمل مطلوب منه تعملوا 2015
تعريف وتحديدا الموافق صندوق النقد الدولي
على اضافه عمرك اليوم سله حقوق السحب
الخاصه اللي بيضم الدولار الامريكي
واليورو والين الياباني بين الاستراليه
وبالتالي اصبحت البنوك المركزيه حول
العالم على الاحتفاظ
حتى اعترافها
الفرنسي بيقول انه رغم الحاله الفريده
للدولار التي لن تختفي بين عشيه وضحاها
الى ان الصين وصفها بانها
الحدود على اتفاقيه تسويه التجاره
والاستثمار بالعملات المحليه تنجح في
تقويض الدولار الدوله مشروع الدوله البنيه
التحتيه الماليه في العالم قائمه على
الدول الفرص ان المدفوعات عبر الحدود سوف
يهيمن عليه الظروف وبالتالي الدول محتله
عندها س ماليه جديده بعيده عن النظام
الاستثناء عن الدولي الخاصه بانه عملتين
محليتين بشكل كامل يعتبر الدولار من اقل
عملات قلبا وبالتالي فهو الانخفاض
والروسي واليوان الثاني في عندنا مشكله ان
وهي تقلب الروبي الروسي العلم جزء رئيسي
من صادرات روسيا ما اعتقد على النفط
والغاز وهي اسواق متقلبه بتاثر على قيمه
الروسيه انا الاعلانات السعوديه شن حرب
نفسي على راسها باغلاق الاسواق بالنفط
منتصف مارس الموضوع الفين وعشرين ترجع
فرض العقوبات الامريكيه والاوروبيه على
روسيا في 2014 الانهيار روبيو فقط خمسين
في المائه من
2014 2016 وفي النهايه لا ان الاعتماد
الكلي على الرجل وان في تسويه المعاملات
التجاريه والاستثماريه بروسيا ولكن يمكن
تسويه ليس بقليل من معاملات العملات
المحليه ولكن بلا شك الجميع مدرك ان العد
التنازلي لزوال السيطره الدوليه على
العالم السؤال دي الوقتي
للقناه موجوده
باختصار رقم واحد وجود اللي بتهرب من
العقوبات الامريكيه وبالتالي الدور على
طرق جديده للابتعاد عن رقم اثنين ومد
والثانيه تسعى للاطاحه بالدولار وتعزيزها
بالنسبه لل هو ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
بالنسبه اليوم ثلاثه او مؤشرات اقتصاديه
داخليه في الولايات تحت ضغط على قيمه
الدور
الانخفاض الموازنه اللي ازداد كل سنه
متوقع يوصل
حاليا اخر سبتمبر القادم
والمؤشر الاخر هو اتفاق الديون الامريكيه
يعني الفين واثنين الفين وثلاثه وتضاعف
الدين الامريكي ثلاث مرات تعريف من سته
اليوم الاثنين وعشرين
الاسباب دي العالم من قبل على متعدد
الاقطاب بعد فقدان الولايات المتحده
الماليه
يستغرق ربما سنه ولكنها لم وصل طلبات كثير
اللي تعليم تجاره العملات عشان كده
مباشره على الانترنيت
بمشاركه نخبه من افضل المدربين في المجال
استخدام الرابط
في النهايه والفيديو
ام
[موسيقى]